all week we've been telling you about
the joy read you never knew the rigidly
progressive race hustling MSNBC anchor
once had very different views and
they've been revealed by newly
discovered excerpts from her long
defunct blog for example read once
complained that immigrants were taking
American jobs imagine that she described
lou dobbs our friend lou dobbs as her
ideological twin on immigration
she told Democrats to spend less time
attacking white people amazingly she
also compared John McCain to the
Virginia Tech shooter and she spread
9/11 conspiracy theories well in April
she commented on some of those blog
posts watch I've spent a lot of time
trying to make sense of these posts
I hired cybersecurity experts to see if
somebody had manipulated my words or my
former blog and the reality is they have
not been able to prove it but here's
what I know I genuinely do not believe I
wrote those hateful things well we
assumed that Reid would once again
continue to blame these new set of
opinions on a mysterious fake hacker cuz
you just saw she's done it before but
now this time she admitted the truth and
said she's sorry so good for her it's
better not to lie so much but there's at
least one outstanding question here a
question that hangs in the air whatever
happened to that FBI investigation that
joy Reid and NBC News ordered up when
they were still pretending that the blog
posts weren't real and were committed by
maybe Vladimir Putin is that FBI
investigations still ongoing and what's
the penalty for using federal law
enforcement to perpetuate a hoax and how
much did it cost and as NBC News gonna
pay back American taxpayers ah joining
us now is a man who's considered these
questions Larry O'Connor associated over
the Washington Times
so Larry this is a real question and by
the way again I just want to say good
for joy Reid for telling the truth it's
always good to tell the truth little
late but they did order up this FBI
investigation and NBC stood behind it
yeah are you allowed to do that in
perpetuation of a hoax which is what
they did
last I checked not so much and I
actually checked with a couple of the
former Department of Justice officials
and they said no that's actually kind of
a federal crime making a knowing false
report to the FBI
and no one knows how much of our
government resources have been spent on
investigating a hoax now that the FBI
isn't spending so much time
investigating political opponents of
Barack Obama one thinks that they they
actually would like to chase down some
serious crimes and not just joy Reid's
fantasies and to cover her own but by
the way and that's let's let's be clear
here her lies and which were reinforced
by her network NBC they were all to just
cover her up it was to make her look
good it was just to protect her job and
apparently she didn't have to because
NBC is gonna stand by her no matter what
yeah and by the way I'm all for Network
standing by their anchors I should just
say well most people are decent and
forgiving and I think that if you say
you know I'm sorry I said that or my
views have changed I think most people
think that's okay I certainly think it's
okay what's not okay is to waste our
time and the resources of federal law
enforcement perpetuating a lie now no
one who does that and there are a lot of
people who do that by the way a lot of
fake hate crimes for example they're
never prosecuted and she won't be
prosecuted but shouldn't NBC have to
repay that money when they get a pass on
it I would think so and I think also I
mean listen not I understand and I'm all
for radio networks forgiving they're not
fire yeah while we're at it let's have
that on the record but I do think NBC
has to answer for a couple of things
here because they were part of this
Tucker they circulated this report from
joy Reid's expert the cybersecurity
expert that said that she had been
hacked that damages their brand because
they're in the business of fact-checking
everybody they disagree with well it's
time for them to actually come clean a
little bit and say yeah this was all
bogus it was wrong there needs to be
some transparency there and yes you're
right at the very least whatever this
ended up costing the federal government
NBC Comcast Universal they should repay
that money well I mean they're liars we
know they're liars they leak the Access
Hollywood tape to the Washington Post we
know that everyone who works at NBC
knows that and they did it for political
reasons and they've never admitted that
they do their own investigation into
that though Tucker I remember they made
a lot of noise about that thorough
investigation still try to find the real
Larry that's right thanks for coming on
Friday night good to see that sucker you
too